you know last time we talked i remember
we talked about the office briefly we
didn't really get into the office
because you know everybody knows a lot
about the office it's like you know we
don't have to talk about everybody loves
the office you were loved your loved
character
but i remember you saying something
pretty profound you're like i was a bit
of a a dick or i was maybe a little hard
at a certain point on that show
and do you think cause i look at the
podcast now and
and soul pancake
which
you know founded soul pancake to create
a space where people from all walks of
life could discuss and question what it
means to be human
and do you think that there was
something that happened to you maybe
while filming in the office or the way
you were or the way you felt like you
were that you needed to change so you
started doing things like metaphysical
milkshake which we'll talk about all
these spiritual things and getting in
the high faith
faith and things like that do you think
that is it did it start kind of back
then or soon after
it's kind of finding yourself who you
are
well you know
part of it is you know i i don't want to
i don't want to be like mr hollywood
recovery guy and there's a whole bunch
of people talking about that but i am in
recovery i have experience with the 12
steps and i've had
you know
issues with alcohol in the in the
distant past and so for me it's part of
that process so it's it's like
um
powerlessness and unmanageability
um around stuff and that goes hand in
hand with ego narcissism and entitlement
of being an addict and then all of a
sudden you add fame and throw fame into
that mix right your character defects
swell up and uh
flare up and whatnot and at the same
time i'm trying to
you know connect with my higher power
and you know become more spiritual and
more grounded in my spiritual life
and trying to be a better person
sometimes succeeding sometimes not so
it's it's like this what i'm describing
is like all of us you don't have to be
an addict to be going through this this
is what this is what we do we have
battles with our ego and we have
times when we're we're trying to make
ourselves and the world a better place
so it's it's part of this struggle but i
will say that
those early years of the office
especially like 2006 2009 right in there
like
it was i was all of i went from this
unemployed character actor to all of a
sudden being like completely
recognizable in this huge tv celebrity
and
and then was getting leads in a lot of
films and getting offered a lot of stuff
and and money and all we were always
broke my wife and i and all of it so
that will inflate your ego and your
narcissism too it was it was a
tremendous challenge so soul pancake the
digital media company which has now kind
of been subsumed by participant media
which is an even larger
uh media company was part of my yeah
it's part of my attempt to kind of
understand myself and other people what
it means to be a human being that we're
all on a philosophical journey we're on
a psychological journey uh we're on a
spiritual journey you know on an
artistic journey and
and metaphysical milkshake the the
podcast that we're doing is kind of born
out of that and that
that whole process